chantal c'est quoi le premier truc que
tu vas faire après le décompte et quand
on veut être des confiné c'est quoi le
premier truc que tu vas faire me
promener dans la rue à l'est dans les
boutiques regarder des choses à vivre
points sans heurt sans horaires voilà
j'ai envie de faire ça à ta dans big flo
c'est vrai que ton frère est beaucoup
plus doué que toi pour ça en fait je
veux faire un truc tu vas voir lille
arras ton frère est plus douée que toi
quoi holy ton frère il est plus doué
côtoient au lit plein de choses notre
notamment pour l'ami mois pour la
musique c'est lui c'est lui c'est lui
qui composent et tout mais si tu veux du
dossier il est beau beaucoup plus fort
avec les mecs c'est un super dragueur
mais son frère son frère tu expliques
ses frères ces îles il est tout terrain
lui c'est ces 24 heures sur 24 qui il
est sur tous les autres
il est surtout les dos alors la mission
la lutte est aussi mais le décès est ton
frère tu sais je suis pas mal quand même
mais je sais qu'il est sur tous les
dossiers
voilà je rappelle que je me suis fait
passer pour lui pour voilà j'ai fait
croire à une meuf tous et à draguer je
crois c'est pour ton frère